yeah take a close look because that's
Shawn Mendes and Camilla Kibeho holding
hands up in San Francisco
[Music]
the pair took their relationship to
NorCal over the weekend where Shawn had
some four stops check them out here
holding hands across a table at Dotty's
true-blue cafe in San Fran and in this
shot Shawn's got his arms wrapped around
Camila and I witnessed lzt quote I feel
like they are for sure dating and I saw
them kiss ass tourists lzt the rumored a
couple ate omelets and pancakes and
mendez picked up the tab
[Music]
et has also learned about a video making
the rounds showing sha mila making out
[Music]
camilla recently talked about sean to
clash magazine revealing he's the person
she's known the longest in this industry
adding quote it's actually a really
beautiful feeling to know that this
person is always going to be in my life
we're always going to love each other
yeah love
but she never confirmed that they're
more than friends
she's amazing like super talented his
songwriter like I do so no I mean I
would never record the actual songwriter
who I clicked with as well as the pair
has been hit with romance rumors for
years though since 2015 when they
released their first collab it was so
spontaneous like we kind of just wrote
it for the sake of writing it not even I
didn't even think that it would be heard
anywhere or like be released anywhere so
when his label picked that as a single I
was kind of like okay cool but I think
like I'm just you know it's really it's
a really cool thing that happened but I
don't think you can plan those things I
don't at the time the pair both told ET
nothing romantic was going on no we are
just friends for Edison's we're not
dating
yeah we're just friends he's like one of
my best friends he's amazing Camila and
Sean have been spending a ton more time
together since seniorita came out though
asuras tall DD quote Camila just got out
of a relationship and sean is on tour
the duo isn't looking to get into
anything serious right now
Camila is also hard at work on her
upcoming album I just feel really like
appreciative of being able to like live
and I feel like I just know what's
important in life right now
so I'm just I'm really happy and I feel
very I don't I feel like really in touch
with my emotions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]